vegas has all sorts of workers working
all sorts of shifts a san francisco tech
company called bolt has experimented
with a four-day work week for three
months and now it's not going back bolt
is an e-commerce checkout company it's
four day work week is meant to drive up
productivity keep employees happy and
reduce burnout the change became
permanent at the beginning of the year
it's actually not about trying to cram
five days into four days the way we
think about it is actually changing the
way we work and being more effective and
efficient during those four days so
we're taking a look at are the are there
meetings that we don't need to have can
we do work a different way are we
focused in prioritizing on the most
impactful work boltz chief people
officer jennifer christie says it's not
about policing workers in fact employee
pay stays the same if you hire the right
people who are who are focused on your
mission and are here to do the great
work that we want them to do empower
them to do it and let them let them
achieve their goals and we monitor
things by goals not ours bolt says most
of its 550 employees now work remotely
since it made the news public bolt says
it's been flooded with interest from
potential employees and says it's also
hearing from other companies who want to
learn more about the four-day work week
most local governments already work a
four-day week to cut costs john langler
live local now
and we know certain departments like
city county north las vegas they've got
that four-day work week we have a couple
former colleagues who work over there
they love it the four-day work week so
it's interesting i have a couple friends
who have that schedule they love it they
they get to work a little bit harder but
they do enjoy that extra time so of
course
not for us here in news though
thanks for staying with us here at for
remember you can join us anytime on
eightnewsnow.com the five o'clock starts
right now
you